vrai qu'on regarde la vidéo qu'a fait
eric zemmour pour nous c'est une vidéo
je vous dis exclusive il a fait que pour
nous il nous a préparé une réponse pour
nous dire voilà pourquoi il trouve que
c'est injuste regardez sa vidéo elle
dure trois minutes la vidéo d'eric
zemmour il n'aura il nous dit tout voilà
tout ce qu'ils pensent regardez c'est
une exclusivité pour touche pas au poids
c'est parti bonsoir à tous bon soir
cyril hanouna c'était trop beau ma joie
aurait été de courte durée hier à 16
heures on m'apprenait que la justice
m'avait relaxé dans un énième procès
politique et quelques heures plus tard
et on me disait que le csa avait décidé
de me contait de comptabiliser mon temps
de parole comme une personnalité
politique
je vous avoue que cette offensive ne m'a
pas vraiment étonné depuis des mois des
ministres du gouvernement castex des
députés en marge s'époumonait contre ma
présence à l'antenne de ces news on se
demandait vraiment ce qui les dérangeait
il paraît donc je dois être
comptabilisés mon temps de parole doit
être comptabiliser
le temps de parole de 90% je devrais
dire 99% des éditorialistes politiques
qui professent tous les mêmes idées de
gauche ne les a jamais dérangé et n'est
jamais venu à l'idée de ces éminences de
comptabiliser leur temps de parole mais
c'est ainsi moi il faut comptabiliser
mon temps de parole en vérité j'ai
toujours émis des opinions politiques
ceux qui me suivent depuis des années le
savent très bien et c'est bien mon droit
en tant que journaliste dont la carte de
presse 57 111 soutient le rappeler même
si ça ne me rajeunit pas
garanti mais droit de d'opinion
d'expression
il n'ya il n'y a absolument rien n'a pas
le droit de censurer mes propos et le
csa en moins que tout autre moins que
toute autre institution n'a le droit de
contrôler les opinions des gens et
encore moins des journalistes d'ailleurs
le président du csa reco l'idée de metz
dans une interview qu'il avait accordée
au figaro le 27 janvier dernier avait
été très clair il avait déjà répondu à
tous les ministres qui demandait ma
comptabilisation de temps de parole
qu'il n'en était pas question qu'on ne
comptabiliserait pas le temps de parole
des éditorialistes politiques parce que
ce n'était pas l'objet de la loi de 1986
et voilà hier le président du csa a fait
mentir ses propos et a n'a pas respecté
la loi qu'il a institué voilà le csa a
montré à révéler sa partialité politique
il suffit d'ailleurs de regarder le
parcours de tous les membres du csa pour
comprendre d'où ils viennent et où ils
veulent aller vraiment le csa n'a pas
n'a pas n'a pas respecté sa mission et
d'ailleurs ça va continuer je vous
l'annoncé d' avance déjà des
journalistes militants comptabilise mes
heures de présence à seignosse pour bien
montrer que l'on ne voit que moi comme
si ces news était la seule chaîne de
tout le paysage audiovisuel français
comme si on obligeait les français à me
regarder tous les soirs à 19h bon vous
avez compris
l'objectif est le même me faire taire
mais je ne me tairais pas